[Musique]
bonsoir jeudi 4 janvier bienvenue dans
le 78 sur TV 78 tout de suite les titres
de cette
édition un début d'année dans le froid
après des températures plutôt douces
pour la saison les thermomètres vont
descendre à partir de ce weekend dans
les ivelin et ils seront la semaine
prochaine dans le négatif les prévisions
à suivre temps idéal donc pour rester au
chaud et déguster une galette des rois
ce dimanche à l'occasion de l'épiphanie
dans le département c'est une
boulangerie de marli Leroi qui a hérité
cette année du titre de meilleur galette
franipani V linoise la maison awin nous
dévoile les secrets de fabrication et
puis des nouveautés une centaine de
naissances en 2023 l'année a été riche
aux EAU safari de toiri qui enregistré
l'an passé l'avenue de 500 100000
visiteurs à quoi s'attendre en 2024 pour
l'un des sites touristiques les plus
prisés sur le territoire interview dans
cette édition et puis dans le 78 on vous
donnera également des idées de sortie à
faire dans les evelines ce weekend mais
on commence tout de suite avec les
informations à retenir de ce jeudi 4
janvier dans le département retour du
froid début des championnats de France
de cyclisme sur piste ou encore un
ivelinois doyen de l'édition 2024 du
Dakar Mathilde Francou vous dit
tout
les gelés matinales sont bien de retour
dans les Yvelines le premier weekend de
janvier sera froid surtout à partir de
dimanche météo France annonce entre 0 et
1°r en moyenne sur l'ensemble du
département mais c'est surtout la
semaine prochaine que les températures
vont chuter lundi il fera jusqu'à -5° à
rouiller et Oudan - 4° à manteljolie et
Versailles et les températures
continueront d'être négatifes tout au
long de la semaine la raison de l'air
polaire en provenance d'Europe du Nord
et de Russie se dirige vers la France
alors petit conseil couvrez-vous bien
écharpe bonnet gants seront de rigueur
et le froid les fera peut-être partir
les chenilles processionnaires se
montrent exceptionnellement tôt cette
saison dans les Evelin habituellement
ces insectes ne sont visibles qu'au
printemps au mois d'avril mais certains
ivelinois ont déjà constaté leur retour
dans les forêts et les jardins pour
rappelle ces chenilles sont hurtiquantes
et présentent un risque sanitaire
important avec notamment des
démangeaisons des réactions cutanées ou
encore des allergies elles peuvent
également être mortelles pour les chiens
et les chats mais alors comment lutter
contre leur prolifération si vous
envoyez rapprochez-vous d'un
professionnel il pourra mettre en place
un traitement phytosanitaire ou un piège
autour du Tron d'arbre concerné du sport
à présent et plus particulièrement du
cyclisme jusqu'au dimanche 7 janvier le
vélodrome national de Saint-Quentin en
Newlin accueille les championnats de
France de cyclisme sur piste une
compétition importante juste avant les
Jeux olympiques de Paris 2024 plus de
140 athlètes venant de toute la France
vont se disputer les titres nationaux
aujourd'hui avaient lieu les épreuves de
poursuite par équipe mais aussi
l'épreuve de vitesse pour les femmes
demain les coureurs s'affronteront sur
l'Omnium une compétition en quatre
épreuves qui récompense le cycliste le
plus endurant enfin ce weekend auront
lieu la poursuite individuelle
l'américaine le kry et la course au
point le point d'org vendredi à 17h pour
lesé preuve de vitesse chez les hommes
tous les jours des médailles seront
décernées enfin on termine par une
information insolite il a 77 ans et il
sera pour la 32e fois au départ du rally
Dakar ce vendredi 5 janvier originaire
de Chatou Jean-Pierre strugot est le
doyen de la course il participe avec la
team MD rally sport au volant d'un buggy
pour en arriver là il a fallu comme tous
les ans franchir à un certain nombre
d'obstacles c'est-à-dire va d'abord
avoir arrivver à un certain âge laavale
du corps médical et puis
surtout obtenir
l'accord familial merci Marie de me
laisser une nouvelle fois partir je sais
que tu es un peu inquiète mais il y a
pas lieu je seraiis prudent et et je
vais assurer comme tous les ans le
septuag se prépare toute l'année à cette
course mythique qu'il ne louperait pour
rien au monde son objectif cette année
arrivé dans les 30 premiers il faut
croire que cette course dans le désert
conserve les repas des Fêtes passé que
revoilà déjà une gourmandise à déguster
tout au long du mois de janvier et ce
dimanche à l'occasion de l'épiphanie
c'est bien sûr la galette des rois dans
le département la boulangerie pâtisserie
hen à marlee le rooi était auréolé en
novembre du titre de la meilleure
galette franipan du département 2024 et
Gabriel Gontier est allé découvrir les
secrets de sa
[Musique]
fabrication généreusement garni doré à
point et surtout croustillante cette
année les galettes frangipan de la
maison Halloween ont été élu meilleur
galette des evelines alors à quelques
heures de l'épiphanie la préparation
s'intensifie
bonjour jérô et Jimmy Halloween
boulangerie pâtisserie Halloween à Marle
Leroi élu meilleur galette desin 2024 on
vous emmène avec nous pour la
fabrication de nos
galettes sacré pour la première fois
cette année les gérants ont mis les
bouchets doubles pour faire face à la
demande et tout commence avec une bonne
préparation de la pâte et là sous vos
yeux voyez la pâte s'étale
gentiment c'est parti allez c'est
parti donc là on va venir détendre notre
notre pâte voilà le but c'est qu'elle se
repose un petit peu sur plan de travail
qui est
réfrigéré VO voilà voilà comme ça elle
se détend un petit peu ça nous permettre
de détailler des abaisses bien rondes
afin d'éviter que les galettes ovalisent
par la suite à la cuisson une fois
étalée la pâte est découpée elle sera
ensuite placée au frais pour 24 heur
après ça place à la garniture à base de
crème d'amande et de crème pâtissière
quasiment l'une et dernièrees étape on
vient poser délicatement le dessus de la
galette étape du chiquetage c'est ce qui
va nous permettre de bien souder le
dessus et le dessous ensemble afin que
la crème franipane ne s'échappe pas au
four pour donner toute sa brillance à la
galette elle est ensuite recouverte
d'une préparation aux œufs elle sera une
nouvelle fois placée au frais pour
plusieurs heures dernière étape avant la
cuisson le rayage il y a plus qu'à
mettre au
[Musique]
forond
et donc maintenant place à la
dégustation voilà on va couper notre
galette çaê le résultat après la la
fabrication vous voyez bien garni et
c'est notamment grâce à cette garniture
que la boulangerie pâtisserie a réussi à
faire la différence remportant deux
titres pour ces galettes on a quand même
cuit une vingtaine de galettes pour
sortir vraiment les les plus parfaites
les critères de notation étai la cuisson
la garniture la
décoration voilà donc on a fait
attention à tous les aspects que ça soit
notre rayage voilà un beau sirop pour
faire briller la galette également grâce
à cette récompense les ventes devraient
augmenter de 50 % malgré son succès le
prix reste inchangé compte 5 € la part
pour savourer la championne des galettes
ivblinoises et si vous n'avez pas envie
de manger de galettes et que le froid ne
vous fait pas peur ce weekend Gabriel
Gontier a sélectionné pour vous quelques
idées de sortie à faire dans les
[Musique]
zblines
[Applaudissements]
aju
eu
[Musique]
alors que 2024 vient de débuter
regardons dans le rétroviseur pour voir
ce qu'il s'est passé l'année dernière
dans le département ce soir le zo safari
de toiri fait le bilan de son année
passée et parle des nouveaux projets
pour l'année 2024 interview
[Musique]
express
une année 2023 plutôt longue compliquée
qui se finit très très bien avec le
festival des lumières sauvages mais
c'est vrai qu'une météo des événements
et donc on a essayé de faire face toute
l'année et puis donc le le le le parc
est resté complètement ouvert et a
continue
[Musique]
d'innover les naissances he plus d'une
centaine de naissances dont les ours les
Orix les lions récemment qui ont
quasiment 6 mois les deux petites liones
et puis les les les lODES éléphants qui
ont ouvert avec beaucoup d'arrivées
aussi il y a eu vraiment de deux
éléphants qui sont arrivés dans ces
dernières années dans cette dernière
année qui ont complété le groupe puisque
aujourd'hui Ben qui était tout seul et
ben aujourd'hui ils sont trois et avec
un nouvel enclos aussi pour les
[Musique]
éléphants on a eu plus de 500000
visiteurs déjà il reste encore quelques
jours pour finir cette année 2023 on va
être un tout petit peu en dessous de
2022 mais pas de beaucoup pas de
loin 2024 on travaille sur la
circulation douce et ce sera le premier
pas puisque les camions brousse partent
juste après les vacances pour passer en
énergie propre et devenir électrique et
à partir du mois de juillet normalement
les deux camions qui circuleront sera
complètement en énergie électrique on a
aussi une nouvelle zone d'hébergement
qui va ouvrir sur les lots arctiques à
base de diglucraft ce sont des petites
maisons en bois qui vont venir
agrémenter encore plus cette immersion
au cœur du monde
[Musique]
animal et à partir de lundi prochain et
pendant tout le mois de janvier ce sont
les mères de 50 ans en Yveline qui
viendront sur sur ce plateau ils nous
parleront des grands projets de leur
ville en 2024 une année olympique bien
sûr avant de se laisser jetons un
dernier coup d'œil aux prévision météo
de
demain comme nous vous le disions en
début d'émission les températures vont
peu à peu baisser dans le département à
partir de ce vendredi le temps sera tout
de même sec dans les Yvelines le matin
compté 6°gr à Versailles et Mantel jolie
5°gr à Houdan et Rambouillet
l'après-midi il fera jusqu'à 10°gr dans
la partie nord des yvelin 9°gr sur le
reste du territoire samedi les maximales
atteindront 6°g et des gouttes de pluie
devraient tomber dans toute la moitié
ouest du département seul le secteur de
Versailles pourrait être épargné en fin
dimanche le temps redevient sec mais il
fera encore plus froid des minimales à
1°gr et des maximales seulement à 3°gr
le thermomètre basculera dans le négatif
à partir de lundi voilà c'est la fin du
78 merci de votre fidélité c'est pour
moi l'occasion de vous souhaiter une
très belle année que 2024 soit plein de
bonheur de réussite et avec une santé de
faire c'est le plus important le 78
revient dès lundi pour une nouvelle
édition d'ici là passer un excellent
weekend sur
[Musique]
tv78